beim thema heute abend ist mein licht
kalbach sondern robert habeck und das
thema ist duschen ist die neue freiheit
die denken jetzt vermutlich was für eine
dämliche these sagt die frau da ich
hätte das auch niemals gedacht dass ich
beim morgendlichen deutschland freiheit
denken würde geschafft hat diese
zugegebenermaßen etwas skurrile
entwicklung unser wirtschaftsminister
robert habeck der hat nämlich vor
wenigen tagen dem spiegel gesagt ich
halte mich an das was mein ministerium
empfiehlt meine dusche zeit habe ich
nochmal deutlich verkürzt und weiter ich
habe noch nie in meinem leben länger als
eine mutige duscht fünf minuten geduscht
ich dusche schnell ja das
wirtschaftsministerium hatte vor kurzem
ihre energiespar tipps für den alltag
veröffentlicht tipps keine verordnung
und nun müsste sich laut hb zeigen wer
bock auf dieses land habe und anderen
helfen wolle ich muss gestehen mir als
bürgerin ist es völlig egal wie lange
unserem wirtschaftsminister posch das
ist seine privatangelegenheit und sollte
es auch bleiben ich möchte auch nicht
wissen wieviel toilettenpapier herbert
pro monat verbraucht oder wie lange er
das wasser beim zähneputzen laufen lässt
es gibt für mich nicht schützen weiteres
als die individuelle freiheit des
bürgers also auch meine und ich möchte
nicht hören dass wenn ich jetzt länger
als eine neue social ich kein bock auf
dieses land hätte ich habe bock aber ich
halte es da eher wie wolfgang kubicki
ich dusche so lange bis ich fertig bin
und jetzt interessiert mich was frau
keller dazu sagen ob sie auch schon beim
duschen die zeit heilt auf die uhr
schaut unter der dusche ja das sage ich
nur mein kind
nein ich dusche ehrlich gesagt kalt und
das mehrere minuten und das ist ganz gut
für den kreislauf und insofern ich finde
das wahnsinn worüber wir jetzt alles
schon diskutieren wir wollen jetzt schon
frieren glaube ich für den frieden und
jetzt weniger duschen für das klima ich
bin gespannt was man sich als nächstes
einfallen lässt wo man uns gängeln darf
im namen natürlich immer eines höheren
gutes und es kommt ja immer moralisch
daher also wer jetzt länger als eine
minute duscht habe ich jetzt richtig
verstanden ist moralisch ein kleines
männlein er so einfach ein gutmensch zu
sein so leicht war es noch nie weil wir
nur eine muss erst ist man dabei ich
würde mir wünschen dass unser minister
habe sich endlich darum kümmert wie wir
alle unsere energiekosten bezahlen
können wie wir ausreichend wasser und
strom haben weil wir leben ja irgendwo
nicht irgendwo in einem dritte welt land
sondern mitten in einem industrieland
und es wäre ganz gut wenn unser
wirtschaftsminister das zur kenntnis
nimmt dass wir eigentlich schon mal
weiter waren und dass alles was er
vorschlägt eigentlich ein schritt zurück
ist und
das ist schlicht den staat ja auch wie
sie sagen nichts angeht wenn wir was wir
zu hause in unseren vier wänden wir
können aber natürlich durch protokolle
vielleicht
anders gesagt weil ich finde das
natürlich ein sehr politisches thema
aber ich glaube eben dass unser nächster
bundeskanzler der habe ich das schon mit
bedacht
die erste wette heute abend ja glaube
ich ich glaube dass er das schon sehr
viel sinn hinter steckt ich hab auch
bevor wir mit dem thema beschäftigt habe
hätte die auge da hat mein gott da geht
nix an wie lang ich dusche aber du
kannst wirklich so viel energie sparen
offensichtlich habe das netz nach
gelesen wenn man eben statt zehn minuten
mit 38 grad wäscht sich wäscht nur acht
minuten auf 8 verkürzt kann man schon so
viel kosten und energie sparen dass es
eben wenn jeder sich daran hält jeder
ein bisschen reduziert wirklich
tatsächlich viel eingespart werden kann
aber auch schon so anderen seite haben
wir hier ein fachmann in der zahlen das
doch also wenn ich ja und mein strom
bezahlen kann ich doch verbrauchen so
viel schnee aber wir wollen doch alle
hier möglich dass putin schaden und in
dem wir dann einfach
energie
unterlagen die experten die am tisch
verfahren heute wenn ich jetzt nur noch
1 minute pro tag dusche und auch meiner
schwester und mein lebensgefährte was
beibringen wie sehr schade ich damit
putin also das bringt ich sag mal
im promillebereich ja und das ist das
ärgerliche wir diskutieren etwas was die
gesamte nation beschäftigt aber
thematisieren nicht die wirklichen
probleme die wir mit der energie krise
haben wir haben eine gasknappheit die
vor der folgt eine stromknappheit
die preise liegen uns um die ohren
dreifach fünffache preise aber viel
entscheidender ist ja was ihm der
wirtschaftsminister nicht thematisiert
ist dass über 50 prozent des gases in
die industrie und das gewerbe geht das
geht eben in die metallverarbeitung das
geht in die chemie das geht in die basf
das geht in die brötchen bäckerei und er
weiß natürlich dass es knapp wird und
bereitet das volk ist darauf for mental
aber in wirklichkeit erwarte ich von
einem wirtschaftsminister dass er dafür
sorgt dass die gefährdeten 5,6 millionen
arbeitsplätze die am gas hängt dass er
sich darum kümmert und er hat das ja
versucht indem wir in katar möglich
gemacht hat und gesagt hat wir wollen
bitte euer gas haben die kataris haben
wir dann aber abblitzen lassen weil sie
sagen unser gast schon ich verkaufe sie
habe für fähig genug für das amt des
wirtschaftsministers na ja er hat ein
problem er hat nämlich ist ein grüner
und er kann natürlich nicht aus der
grünen mentalität und die grüne
mentalität sagt ja wir müssen unsere
eigenen
kohlebergwerke stilllegen aber die
gleiche regierung die jetzige hat den
kolumbianischen präsidenten angebaggert
er möchte doch bitte in einen tagebau
erweitern damit wir kohle kriegen aber
in der lausitz da werden die
kohlebergbau um acht jahre verkürzt das
gleiche gilt um zum zum gas wir haben
über der unter der norddeutschen
tiefebene ein riesiges erdgasvorkommen
für 30 jahre hätten wir überhaupt kein
problem damit putin mit katar mit wem
auch immer wir müssen es nur fördern
aber das will natürlich keiner das ist
schon seit den letzten 20 jahren runter
gegangen und man müsste in etwa 1100
meter tiefe das schiefergestein
erschüttern und dann kommt das gas raus
wir wissen genau wo es liegt und es gibt
experten die sagen
wir können es in einem jahr fördern aber
das tun wir nicht sondern holen uns
flüssiggas aus amerika das übrigens mit
der gleichen technik gefördert wird und
das dritte ist wir wissen alle mitten im
winter am 31.12 werden drei
kernkraftwerke abgestellt und da bietet
sich ja auch um unser das wollen wir
aber das habe er klebt ganz frisch von
heute eher wie olaf scheint sich dazu
äußert
bringt nichts nicht nicht selber gucken
was in deutschland den boden dass ich
glaube in deutschland ist nicht so viel
im boden dass wir diese abhängigkeit von
damit beseitigen können
zeigen aber leider eben die halbe
wahrheit
und es ist einfach so ich will dass
immer wieder
kernenergie kernkraftwerke machen ja nur
strom und keine wärme der fehler ist der
wenn sie kernkraftwerke abstellen wie
das jetzt geplant ist dann müssten
gaskraftwerke hochgefahren werden denn
wir haben ja gar keine genügend
kohlekraftwerke das heißt wir schieben
das gas was so dringend gebraucht wird
in unseren arbeitsplätzen aber auch
zuhause fürs duschen das werden wir
zusätzlich verbrennen und deswegen sage
ich mal auch da ist eine
doppelzüngigkeit am werke wir
importieren aus tschechien aus
frankreich über kernenergie strom
eigenen wir wollen wir nicht mehr den
wollen wir nicht mehr benutzen und das
wäre wenn man ein beispiel geben wenn
sie die drei kernkraftwerke ab stellen
in deutschland dann haben sie so viel
strom auf so viel strom verzichtet wie
die gis fast die gesamte
solarplatten in deutschland also 2,2
millionen solardächer produzieren ja und
das will ja die bundesregierung jetzt
verstärken das heisst also jetzt müssen
wir erstmal fünf bis sechs jahre
solarplatten bauen damit wir überhaupt
das ersetzen was durch die drei großen
kernkraftwerke ersetzen dass der
kommende gleicher noch ganz detailliert
zum glück ist ein wichtiges thema aber
ich habe hier schon von der anderen
seite gemerkt neckar aber sprach er das
nein doch ich bin neugierig und zwar
wegen der erdgasvorkommen in der
norddeutschen tiefebene
darunter
wie wie realistisch ist das denn oder
wie schnell könnte man das so zu tage
fördern wir wissen genau wo es liegt es
gibt aber leider in deutschland ein so
genanntes fracking verbot das ist ein
gesetzliches verbot das hat man damals
unter merkel
verabschiedet weil man dachte auch wir
haben doch dass russen gas das ist doch
reichte auch wir müssen uns noch nicht
anstrengen in deutschland wir könnten
doch einfach so tun als ob stört ja man
ist es natürlich klar wenn sie irgendwo
eine gasförderung haben die nachbarn
haben das nicht so gerne es gibt immer
ärger natürlich aber wir können doch
nicht im ernst glauben dass wir eine so
hoch entwickelte industriegesellschaft
wie wir sie sind
versorgen können mit mit wind und sonne
wind und sonne machen im gesamten
energiemix gerade mal fünf prozent aus
davon werden wir die nächsten zehn
zwanzig jahre nicht alleine unseren
energiebedarf decken können und deswegen
ist doch die erste bürgerpflicht eines
ministers zu sagen was haben wir denn
selbst dann lass uns mal schnell ein
programm machen dass wir im nächsten im
übernächsten winter das eigene gas haben
das zweite ist wir fahren die
kohlekraftwerke hoch das geht ja gar
nicht anders und dann werden noch viel
schöner wenn er dann sagen würde und
dann scheiden wir das co2 ab denn wir
wollen ja auch dem klima gedanken
rechnung tragen das kann man in das
gibt's die deutsche technik die kann das
co2 oben öffnen dessen wird ja vor allem
mit infantilen energiespartipps ich
empfinde es als infantil ich muss
nämlich als mündige bürgerin der mann
nicht zu sagen wie sie duschen soll er
ist übrigens ein anderer spar tipp der
hing in düsseldorf am werbebanner die
gefriertruhe seimetz abtauen wo ich
dachte also das habe ich schon mit 14
jahren von meiner oma gelehrt aber gut
dass es mir jetzt mir jetzt auch die
politik beibringt aber wie sehen sie das
denn als bürger wenn sie diese
energiespartipps des
wirtschaftsministeriums lese also
persönlich wenn ich das so höre kann ich
nur mit dem kopf schütteln
ich fühle mich bevormundet das heißt ich
glaube jeder hat verstanden dass ein
klimawandel kommt dass wir uns verändern
müssen aber das kostet ja auch richtig
viel geld das heißt wenn wir unseren
staat wenn wir unsere wirtschaft
schwächen indem wir sagen okay guck mal
wie ihr klarkommt dann werden wir auf
dauer auch den diese energiewende werden
wir irgendwann nicht mehr bewältigen
können weil uns einfach das geld dafür
fehlt und als unternehmer habe ich das
schon große sorge bei uns auch die
energiekosten
gehen durch die decke und ich kann da
nichts gegen tun